In the game of Thrones people,
dragons.
Those aren't real drag and that's dope
as fuck. Did you watch last night?
I didn't. I did. Was it good?
Spoiler alert. It was awesome.
It was awesome just to see everything.
I just want to see it.
I just was happy to see a new episode.
I'm going to be so sad when that
show gets canceled. I'm such a Dork.
You've watched it all the way up and about
doing the prequel or the beginning of
it for serious,
but they haven't [inaudible] whoever
the fuck people are that are doing it.
You just keep doing things.
Whoever those people that are writing
and producing it and putting it together
and and keep hiring those actors to
play different people. I don't care.
I lost my way after like maybe three
seasons. How many seasons does it been on?
Like five. Fuck up. You lost your way.
Go back and start from scratch and learn
all the names of these places in the
make believe thing.
[inaudible] and the whatevers.
How much do I have to know Joe? I
know, but you know how to make bread.
Just keep making it delicious bread.
I do. And you're doing simple.
A Martini. A little bread. A little run
and live your life. Yeah, we'll jog.
How much, why do I have to top five?
Do I have to control everything?
I would like to nef oh,
catch back up with it. Yeah,
it's good. Right? People like it.
So you're going to like let this whole
season play by without you being caught
up. I F I almost last night was just
going to watch, just jump, jump in.
Who cares if I was there
any show that you never get?
Like please tell me you gave up on the
walking dead. Yes. Thank you. Yeah,
I stopped that one.
Is there any show that you haven't
given up on that you've been steadfast?
That I stay whatever you binge. They
still watch? Uh, you haven't quit?
No, there's none that I'm currently
watching. I just watched Russian doll.
What does that, it's on Netflix. That
was good. Like an assassin or something.
Now she's, she's uh, she dies every
episode. It's like groundhog day.
Yeah, it was pretty good. And, uh,
no, I've seen all the big ones.
I don't know who's arc.
Ozark IA. One season of it.
You didn't watch season
two now was I supposed to?
I don't know how you just shut it off.
You don't want to know what happened.
I don't know.
I forget.